One of the things that's a challenge in understanding
how something as simple and small as a gene
can affect something as complicated as human
behavior is that it takes a long time for
those effects to be manifest.
And we had been doing a study of marriages
that started 20 years ago, it started in 1989.
So one of the things that we noticed as we
started studying couples -- especially over
time is that some couples are in these relationships
that are very emotionally difficult.
A lot of anger and sadness and contempt.
And the marriages just get really miserable.
Others have similarly toxic environments,
but they seem to do OK.
So this is not what we were expecting.
We were expecting the emotions to pretty much
determine how happy people were with their
marriage, regardless.
But it wasn't the case.
And we started thinking that maybe the answer
lies in their genes.
Slight differences in the genetic make up
of individuals could incline them to be more
or less sensitive to the emotional quality
of their marriage.
So we're interested in a gene that regulates
serotonin in the brain.
A lot of the drugs that are used to treat
depression act on the serotonin system in
the brain.
This is clearly a very important chemical
for determining the nature of our emotional
lives.
So the serotonin transporter gene has two
commonly occurring variations: one is the
long allele and one is the short allele.
So when we got into this area, the prevailing
view was that if you had the short alleles,
it was just bad.
There were a number of studies that suggested
that people who had the short alleles had
a higher risk for developing depression and
a number of terrible outcomes.
But the pendulum was starting to shift to
think about this not as a risk gene, but as
a sensitivity gene.
So our thought was maybe it's not that you're
just going to have bad reactions but you're
going to have more of the reactions that you'd
expect given the environment you were in.
People with the short alleles look at cartoons
or funny films —they laugh more.
In a situation that's embarrassing, and we
had a kind of a karaoke task, people with
the short alleles they get more embarrassed.
So it didn't seem that the short allele produced
a particular kind of emotional response, it
just produced a bigger emotional response
across the board.
And so that was the clue to us that when we
looked at marriage, that we would find that
the short allele people would be doing really
well in marriages that were emotionally positive
and really poorly in marriages that were emotionally
negative.
So people with the long alleles, what's determining
whether they're satisfied or dissatisfied
with their marriages?It could be any of a
millions things, you know, it might be how
much money they're making.
It might be whether their kids are doing well.
But it wouldn't be this sort of emotional
substrate of their relationship.
So it's important to step back and ask:well,
how big of difference is this?
Could I see it with the naked eye?
And I think you can't.
I think these genetic variants produce slight
biases.
Having the short allele may make our emotional
responses just a little bit bigger.
And just one incident isn't going to make
much of a difference, but if you start thinking
of like 20 years in the life of a marriage
and about hundreds of emotions every day -- In
the aggregate this becomes something that
really does make a difference.
So how about if we could kind of reconstruct
a personal genome and we knew enough about
the function of each gene so we could really
start to get a picture of how all these genes
affected us and how they made us the person
that we are.
But we are so far away from that now.
We are just at the very beginning of being
able to understand a few of these genes.
So stay tuned, we're just getting started.
As complicated, as mysterious, and extraordinary
as relationships are -- there is science that
can be done here.
There are these understandable forces that
are driving even these most complicated kind
of parts of our lives and the value of good
science and careful science is when it really
starts to help us understand some of these
mysteries.